المقاولون
العالم يواجهه تحديات غير عاديه نواجه
ازمه تلو الاخرى
19 لم تنتهي
بينما انها بدات في العام 2019 لا يزال
العمل مستمر
الغذائي والامن المالي وامن الطاقه التي
اخذت العالم على حين يغره ولا سيما في
الدول الناميه
كذلك موضوع الاسمده يجب ان لا ياخذ بكل
سهوله
وان لم نتخذ اجراءات مباشره لضمان امدادات
الاسمده بصوره كافيه باسعار ضمن المتناول
فان العام القادم 2023 سوف يكون عاما اشد
صعوبه
ان ازمه اليوم التي نعيشها قد تصبح اشد
وطاه
وازمه الغد قد تكون ايضا متجليه في المواد
الغذائيه والامر الذي سوف يؤثر على
المحاصيل في كافه انحاء العالم بالنسبه
للدول الثمانيه الناميه التي تعد اكثر
عرضه
للصعوبات التي ستواجه تحديات كبيره في هذا
الغزون نواجه ايضا ان النظام والامن
العالمي العالميين يخضعان الاختبار الكبير
اصحاب السعاده
اليوم عيون العالم
تركزوا على اجتماعنا هذا هل سوف نكون
قادرين في تحقيق النجاح
ام اننا سوف نكون
في مواجهه فشل اخر اضافه الى مجموعه
اعمالنا الفاشله السابقه من وجهه نظري فان
مجموعه قمه العشرين يجب ان لا تفشل وبصفه
رئيسا لمجموعه قمه ال 20 فان اندونيسيا
فعلت ما بوسعها
لسد لهذه القوه الواسعه لكن النجاح لا
يمكن ان يتحقق الا اذا ما عملنا كلنا دون
ايتنا بالالتزام على تصديق هل هو في
اختلافاتنا وان نقدم شيئا ملموسا شيئا
يعود بالنفع على العالم اصحاب السعاده
اندونيسيا
تحتوي على
17000 جزيره واكثر من 300
عرض
وجنس واكثر من 300 لغه محليه
وتعمل الديمقراطيه بالمستوى الناجح حتى
على مستوى القرى الصغيره النائيه
الامر الذي تجلى بصوره واضحه من خلال
الانتخابات البلديه وانتخابات القرى
وبصفتنا همم نحمل رئاسه مجموعه قمه
العشرين فان الحوار هو الكفيل بيسد الفجوه
في اختلافاتنا وانطلاقا منها
يجب ان يتبلوا ذلك في قمه العشرين
خيارا فان التعاون سوف يكون مطلوبا
ويقعوا على كاهلنا مسؤوليات ليس فقط
لاتجاه الشعوبنا بل الاتجاه شعوب العالم
مجتمعين
فهذا يعني التحلي بالمسؤوليه واحترامي
القوانين والاعراف الدوليه وكذلك احترامي
ميثاق الامم المتحده
لتكون مسؤولين يعني ان نخلق حاله يكون
فيها الكل رابحا
والمسؤوليه تعني ان
انه يجب علينا ان نسدل الستاره على الحرب
واذا لم تنتهي الحرب وتضع او زارها فسوف
يصعب علينا ان نمضي قدما
وان لم تسدوا الحرب ستارتها للابد فقد
يصعب علينا ان نحقق الاستقرار من اجل
مستقبل
الاجيال المقبله
والمستقبل لشبابنا
يتوجب علينا ان ندخل العالم في دهاليزي
هذا الصراع
وان ندخل في حرب بارده جديده اصحاب
السعاده اصحاب المعالي
يحدثوا اندونيسيا الامل ان مجموعه القمه
العشرين سوف تكون حافزا
لانتعاش الاقتصاديه شامل في خضم هذه
صعوبات فان قمه ال 20 مستمره بالعمل
لتقديم نتائج
الاموال من اجل مواجهه الجائحه المستقبليه
واموال اللي دعم الدول ذات الدخل المنخفض
ومساعدتها للوقوف على قدميها وتشجيع
وتسريع
انجاز انجازاتي اهداف الالفيه
ويتجل ذلك من خلال التعاون ودعم
انتعاش اخضر للاقتصاد العالمي وفقا لميثاق
بالي حول العمليه الانتقاليه ثلج نسعى
دائما
لننفذ ما نقوله وانتم تضاهي كلماتنا افعال
كلماتنا بافعالنا باخذه مكالمتي لابد لنا
من ان نستخدم الحكمه في مشاطره مسؤوليتنا
دعونا نعمل
ودعونا نتعاون من اجل العالم وفقا للشعار
التعافي معا التعافي بشكل اقوى
اصحاب السعاده
هذا ما اود ان اقوله لكم في الكلمه
الافتتاحيه وبعد ذلك سوف نبدا
بالمشاورات المغلقه
وبذلك اطلب بكل احترام من وسائل الاعلام
ان تغادر هذه القاعه شكرا جزيلا